allora siamo in taxi che stiamo andando
per iscritto che
si trova la casa di carrie di sex and
the city ed è una delle mete che insomma
doveva assolutamente visitare più new
york salvo e molto contento non vedo
l'ora
anche perché dovrà fare un bellissimo
shooting di due ore se vedete notate
pure la tenuta dal sex and the city e
niente sono molto presa bene non vedo
l'ora di farlo vedere
ed eccoci qui siamo a ferri street la
via dove si trova alla casa di carrie
siamo al numero 82 devo arrivare al 66
quindi retto salvo
fammi il video della reactions io che
arriva la mente la casa è solo tipo
morta quindi venite con me proseguiamo
stavo avvicinando
eccola
è la chiave
ci pensiamo noi
un sapone fitto strano vedere le vergini
tutti c'è la catena perché teoricamente
la si possa farle fonte disinnesca le ma
io me ne frega eroe satiro sopra perché
capita una volta nella vita di stare qua
aps tutte le foto e video di vedere
pubblicati sul mio instagram marina
ufficio quindi mi raccomando andate a
vedere dopo per iscritto numero 66
quindi casa di carrie vuoi non passare
da magnolia bakery dove carey mangiava i
cupcakes vuoi non mangiar tim cup cake
adesso come facciamo
molto bravo comunque era buono il caffè
o la saggia
allora io stavo camminando per finte
veniva venduto misure dico ma io ai
questo posto lo conosco
e infatti è
madri
e
niente chiamati ai sex in the city si
ricorderanno cosa è successo qui queste
infatti era
kerry era entrata per riconsegnare un
libro e si è innamorata della sala
dove ha scoperto che si potevano anche
insomma cerebrale dei matrimoni ha
deciso quindi di celebrare il matrimonio
come street in qua dentro
peccato che
proprio quel punto di dove sta passando
una corsa autista
non attacco di panico prende e se ne va
il abbandona quattro ragazzi siamo
dentro la biblioteca che questo angolo
ve lo ricorderete tutti voi amanti sex
and the city
l'angolo
mica riviste
anche l'arrivo di mister
gli organici ad agitarsi si fa
non lo trova più le ha portato via santi
paglia
ma diciamo che chiamano i servizi
non è pronto
parla e quindi le cadette lei con cena
super grammatica ed era proprio qui
all'entrata all'ingresso della
eccoci sul ponte di brooklyn
siamo arrivati un po in ritardo ma quale
amore gare al tramonto c'è una fine di
tre volte lo si vede
rosa ed io gli occhiali forse è ora che
mi tolga perché non c'è persona questo è
il nostro ponte una bella
ma soprattutto ci troviamo
miranda si ritrova ciao
compagno che era di poter operare
comunque litigano e decidono che si
vogliono tornare insieme si devono
ritrovare devono presentarsi sul ponte
di propriano a una determinata ora è di
ritrovarci a questa bellissima serata
tornano a rimanere a parte né dall'altra
si abbracciano
baci abbracci musica romantica ed è
subito tuffato
e qui noi ci siamo davanti a tim fain
direttamente è stato girato colazione da
tiffany con audrey apac
aprire la pista vie in crociera
la squadra fretta
eccoci davanti a uno dei luoghi che
meglio rappresenta in tutta new york
costi più sto parlando
il m poi dal museum of art ma in
particolare di questi tiri farini della
scalinata dove insomma per essere da
venivano
quindi adesso non staccheremo perché
salvabile fare uno shopping in stile
gossip girl sta bene l'autrice come voi
mi manca mi manca la fascetta in testa
quella di modella
eccoci qui c'è davanti a via quadronno
che è il bar
nella seconda stagione di gossip girl si
gira una scena di blair
che stava andando a prendere
e si scoccia incontra serena e quindi si
nasconde dietro un albero per aria
non lo facciamo la ripresa
ma non è qui
perché
mi sono documentata e c'era stata
una scena avevano creato ancora c'era i
pezzetti figli
ma era il 1998 questo party ha cambiato
gestione di via cento mezzanotte quindi
l'angolo era questo ne conservo insomma
era un negozio di cioccolatini la maison
di cioccolato
guardatelo visto
davanti al negozio di caramelle che
appare anche così
e cosa fai non entri cioè chiaro
caramelle da portare in italia b7
evidenti servita a portare in italia
oggi li mangiavano in viaggio e non
arriveranno italia
va bene questa invece le grand central
station un luogo fondamentale per gossip
per perché qui
da qui è partito
da qui tutto iniziò
[Musica]
e concludiamo il tour di gossip girl
davanti al new york palace hotel dove
leva ciak e la famiglia quante bugie ed
è questo qua ho scoperto tra l'altro che
alba all'intervallo all'interno servono
semplici che hanno chiamato proprio
gossip semplici non ora insomma della
serie tv siamo un po in ritardo che è un
quartiere se non avremmo provato
concludiamo questo video con una perla
finale per gli amanti del diavolo veste
prada me compresa io adoro quel film
siamo proprio qui davanti alla sede di
raiway del film che nella realtà non è
la sede di rame ma la serie di mcgraw
hill e niente quindi il video finisce
qui ma io so aspettare miranda presley
john juanda
oddio se arrivando sta arrivando
[Musica]